This is the Reason interview with
Nick Gillespie, and today I'm
talking with Magatte Wade, who was
born in Senegal and is Director
of the Center for African Prosperity
at the Atlas Network.
She's the founder and CEO of many
companies, including Skin Is
Skin, which sells a series of
skin products.
And she's the author of the new
book, "The Heart of A Cheetah:
How We Have Been Lied to about
African Poverty, and What That means
for Human Flourishing".
Magatte, thanks for talking to
Reason.
Nick. Thanks for having me.
It's a pleasure.
So, uh, let's, uh,
what's the elevator pitch for the
book?
The elevator pitch for the book is
what you said.
You know, how we've been lied
to it, how we have been lied to
about African poverty and what it
means for human flourishing.
So basically, so many people around
the world, um, have been appalled
by why Africa to this
day, including many Africans,
why Africa to these days till the
poorest region in the world,
despite, you know, all of its
riches, uh, starting with a
very young population.
And I'm sure we'll talk about that.
But, when it comes
to that, I realize that almost
no one, you know, puts on
the table, the right diagnosis as to
why that is the case.
So the book is about what is
the right diagnosis as well as
to why this continent is still the
poorest in the world.
And then so 80% of the book spends
time on that, because we need to
make sure that we got the diagnosis
right so we can have a good
solution. And then 20% of a book
goes on to solutions, and then
from there, from having read the
book, then we invite
people into our cheetah generation
movement, where we're actually
taking all the concrete steps that
the solutions parts talks about.
Let's, uh, talk about that kind of
the controlling metaphor of the book
really is the cheetah and
the cheetah generation.
You know, a cheetah is obviously an
African animal.
Uh, it's it's pretty cool.
Where does that term come from,
and what does it signify for you?
Yes. So the reason
why I am cheetah everything
is because of, uh, my
beloved professor George Ayittey,
a Ghanaian economist who we lost
earlier this year.
And he taught for many years at
American University in D.C..
I know him.
Taught for many years.
Exactly. And was part at some point,
I think, of the Brooklyn Institute,
if I'm not mistaken.
So anyway, so professor
it for me, I think, for people to
understand why, um, why
him, why cheetah, and why all of
this? You have to understand that
back in 2007, I
was back then a young,
you know, Ted fellow.
We were actually also the African
fellows were the first Ted fellows.
We were the, the cohorts, the
first cohort.
And so as that basically they went
around and they, um, they,
you know, the people of Ted and
allies and the people who worked
with them picked 100 of
young Africans from back home
in the diaspora everywhere.
And they felt really this cohort
of young Africans are really
onto something and they're doing
amazing work. Most of us were
entrepreneurs, but you also had
artists of various types of
creatives. It was wonderful.
So. So Ted was my first time at Ted.
You know, we were in Arusha in an in
Tanzania and, uh, you know, there
were people like Larry Page,
Sergey Brin, um, Bill Gates, I mean,
everyone was there.
Mention, of course, Bono was there,
right?
Bono was there, everyone
was there. Everybody really in the
world back then. But was somebody
was there because Africa was
hot. They were like, let's see what
we, you know, let's see how we move
forward.
And so, um, uh,
you know, basically, and
me, I was there and, you know, I was
an entrepreneur already working in
Silicon Valley. And a little bit I
was I was still very much, um, if
you could qualify me that way, I was
very much still a lefty, you know,
like, uh, because I was also
a do-gooder. So not that the two of
can be conflated, but anyway, that
was more me.
And I was barely at this idea
that, um, it is fine, but
trade is better.
I was still fine, even with aid,
uh, foreign aid.
So that's where I was, you know,
but, um, definitely starting to be
served by reality in terms
of, um, you know, like what dots
connect and don't connect, right?
And so here I am. It's a mindset I
walked in with.
And then this was the first time in
my life, but I heard, uh, people
being so articulate about,
um, the disasters of foreign
aid. But the reason why, you know,
just being so vocal about it and
Africans, not non-Africans,
they were like people like, and, uh,
people like George Ayittey, but him,
his talk really crippled me because
when he was talking about so what
George's title, the title of his
talk was "Hippos versus Cheetahs".
And very much he was making this,
uh, differentiation in mindset
was not so much about age.
Are you African? non-African?
It's about the mindset about about
Africa and its, uh, path forward.
And he had, um, he
had made this differentiation
between the hippo mentality.
These are the people who
still believe, you know,
uh, but colorism sets us back.
People who believe that slavery, um,
even though we're out of it, sets us
back. Um, and when
you put them all together, it's more
or less the victimhood mentality.
And also our leaders, you know, our
current leaders who are actually the
first beneficiaries of a status quo
in terms of the mindset.
Right. Because, you know, as long
as we stay in victimhood, we don't
try to fight more, uh, we stay
poor and the foreign aid keeps on
pouring in to fix supposedly better
fabric. But poverty and so
but whole side of the argument.
He identified it as the
hippo generation, again,
mindset instead of generation, think
of  mindset.
And then when you are facing off
with home, the cheetah generation
and um, definitely, you
know,
um, George said, you know, he's
like, you're definitely one of my
early everybody on that stage
for all of us. They're all these
African cohort.
He said, you guys are my cheetahs,
you know. And so we were so proud.
I was just like, yeah, it's.
Very flattering, right, that you
don't I mean, if you're a, you
know, either a cheetah or a hippo,
it's like I'm going with you.
Yeah.
I love that.
It was so cool.
Yeah. No idea. And, and, you know,
uh, Nick, what George did for
me and the all 99 other,
you know, fellows, it's
it's. I think George just, uh,
I felt for me, at least, he just
carried on the work with my grandma
I did with me in my early days.
But anyway, I go back.
So George was a and he said, facing
off with a cheetah. Generation said
the future generation is a
generation of Africans with
a mindset that really are waiting
for no one. They're not going to
wait for the government. They're not
going to wait for before you need.
They're not going to wait for
everyone. No, wait for no one.
They they believe in themselves.
They know they have the tools and
they're going to just they're just
going to get it done. And he said,
the future of our continent
lies on the back of a cheetah.
And he his whole thing was
runs run, cheetahs
run, have a best run of your life.
And for me, I interpret that as as
well. Just like the cheetah runs in
leaps and bounds.
Yeah. Uh, but time to catching up
for Africa is.
Over what type of leapfrogging is
upon us.
And so even there the, the,
the, the, um,
the metaphor, it goes very well.
So but she does because speed
a being agile but also
before a cheetah goes for the when
she does a hunting, 80% of her time
is spent on strategizing.
You'll see them kind of sitting, uh,
laying around, you know, looking
like we're just, you know, taking
some a break or whatever.
And then, uh, if you don't pay
attention, you don't know what's
going on. You think it's all cool,
but if you start to pay attention,
you'll see that there's maybe an
antelope or a gazelle not too far
away. But when the cheetah start to
run the way you see them spreading,
first of all, and then going one
corner you this one corner that one
could and and one among them is in
charge of the race.
And as you know, they go from zero
to 60 or 65 three, I mean, something
wild.
And so they just go for it.
And it's just, it's just beautiful.
So it's about strategizing.
It's about preparing before you go
for the fight. And when you go you
have to be precise, you have to you
have to go for speed and just get it
done. So that's what the
cheetah generation is.
And, um, it's a mindset.
It's not about your age.
You said about, uh, are you African
or not or non-African?
It's not about are you an African
living on the continent or in the
diaspora?
It's very much, do you believe?
But we have a bright future.
And do you believe?
And a bright future will be achieved
by the free markets.
And and you know, you talk about
that TEDx conference in particular
because Iita was there, as well
as, uh, Andrew Mwenda, who you
mentioned. But Bono,
I mean, what was fascinating
about that, that was the beginning
of a shift in his mindset.
He had been, uh, you know, people
I think he himself would agree
that he has something of a Christ
complex, of a Savior complex.
And he had been, you know, to his
credit, he had been trying to talk
up, how do we help the developing
world? How do we help Africa?
And he came out of that,
uh, you know, essentially within a
couple of years saying that trade is
better than aid.
So the IATA, the
Mwenda message, the one that you are
selling now has had real
impact on, you know, on
at least some people involved in
this space.
Um.
Yeah, know for sure.
So yes.
Because what happened there, Bono,
when he was hearing people like
Mwenda, when he was hearing people
like, um, you know, I it
and many others kind of pushing back
on the aid rhetoric.
I think for him it was a very first
time. But people like him,
uh, where we're actually
hearing the other side of a story
from Africans.
Yeah. Because up till then they
spent most of their time with, um,
you know, benefactors of the status
quo in terms of, uh, the,
uh, consensus around why Africa was
poor. Right?
And then it all landed them on
foreign aid.
And so our leaders back home were
benefiting from that, you know,
basically lining the pockets.
And the donor aid community
was benefiting from that, especially
government to government aid,
because it's, uh, it's a way of
being able to practice, um, you
know, neo colonialism in a, in a
soft way, but still.
So what's not to love for the
different governments that benefit
from. But, um, you know, uh,
scenario but this world and I
think Bono has always been involved
with people who actually benefit
from that, whether it's the IMF,
the, um, the world Bank.
I mean, that whole structure of
what some of us would call poverty
Inc, you know, that
rhetoric really benefits them.
Uh, so I think Bono has been
specifically more speaking to them
and maybe some of your direct
recipients, who which person
who is getting access to clean water
is going to say, oh, that didn't
help me or whatever, but I but I
think what he has never been able to
hear at children was people like,
uh, Georgia youth de, you know,
very, very much together
very much, you know, know what
they're talking about and yet had
a very different viewpoint.
And I think it was a shock.
I think the fact that you went to
hack on window is, um,
it was because that's what he did.
He heckled a speaker, an African
on stage in his continent,
on his continent, saying
aid is no good for us.
And Bono, I think, which I
think it was just one of his
electric shocks that one gets.
And his first jerk reaction,
it was just a knee jerk reaction.
You have a nerve which is reacting,
and I think that's what happened.
But eventually, as he
went on and that's what I say to
people, I feel like Bono.
I'm not surprised Bono came to
our side on these issues, because
I think I know Bono always cared.
He may not have gone about it right
away, but he always cared.
And the fact that he truly cared
and which, by the way, is a crux of
a book as well.
If you truly care,
you cannot be blind
to the evidence.
And it's like in that,
in that it's one of the exchanges
that you recount in the bucket at
that, uh, moment in
Africa. Uh Mwenda
had asked the crowd, you know,
can you show me a country that's
gotten a lot of aid that has done
well? And Bono was like, yeah,
Ireland.
Um, and it's fascinating because
Ireland has a that
one of the poorest countries on the
planet, certainly in Europe.
And when uh, uh, rebutted
that by saying no, you were given
opportunity, like when the Celtic
Tiger took off, it was because
they essentially opened.
In themselves up through a series
of business reforms.
Tax regulation two.
Engaging and integrating into world
markets rather than just getting
money, uh, dropped from helicopters
and things like that.
Exactly.
Um, I want to get to your,
uh, uh uh, the autobiographical
parts of the book, which are
fascinating and everything, but as
long as we're talking about, uh, you
know, kind of the question of
foreign aid and African development,
it's worth thinking about.
Not long ago, I was talking to, uh,
Johan Norberg, a Swedish economist
who, you know, pointed out that in
the early, like in the late 50s and
early 60s, as decolonization
was taking place around the world,
most smart people were betting on
Africa. Africa was doing better
than Asia as a continent.
Um, and Africa got a lot of aid.
Asia got relatively
little. But Asia has been doing
better. So this goes to that
question of, you know, trade versus
aid.
Um, but, uh, you
in the book and in your work, you've
really kind of
you, you know, the critique of
the kind of aid mentality or
the, you know, whether we want to
call it a, uh, you know, a great
white savior or outsiders
from Africa who are going to come in
and fix everything.
You have written a series of
critiques, and there is a blistering
one in the book of Columbia
University developmental economist
Jeffrey Sachs, who was a
major force in creating and pushing
the United Nations Millennium
Development Goals, uh, which
were kind of like for the 21st
century, this was the, the,
the new way that the, you know,
the wealthy part of the world or the
global north was going to help the
global South.
Um, in what does
what do people like Jeffrey
Sachs fundamentally
get wrong?
What is what is wrong with the
framework that they are trying to
impart on the developing
world?
Well, I think
that, um, the
part that someone like Jeffrey Sachs
has understand, although he,
you know.
Yeah, you can call yourself an
economist. Um, we all know our
issues with Stiglitz and people like
that. But to me, it's just not
understanding. At the end of the
day, the way the world works and not
understanding economics.
I'm sorry. You know, um,
and and also, in the end, it's
not really rocket science.
And maybe that's why, uh, for
people who are always looking for
complexity, um, they
fail to see that.
I think for folks like him,
it's very something very unsettling
about this idea that, um,
you know, the market can take care
of things, right?
And so, um, the reason why
I say he doesn't understand
economics, he doesn't understand how
things work is I'll just give you
examples, because the thing is,
people like Jeffrey Sachs and his
team came to me.
Um, and what
was the book a need amongst?
Uh, she has a book, an amazing book
that I would recommend everybody to
read. I mean, I think I mentioned it
in the. Yes.
And I gotten the name of it.
Um.
Really? Yeah.
I think it's ideally something like
that. So anyway, so for people
listening to us and, uh, the story
with Jeffrey Sachs, um,
Jeffrey Sachs, you know, celebrity
economist back then, um,
has said, I mean, he thought he
could fix poverty and so forth, but
then what he did is basically set up
a village, what they would call the
Millennium development or, uh,
Millennium Development Villages.
And they're they just went on
to basically do a very top
down type of, um, approach
to economics.
And so if only people
grew these type of crops and
did it in this way and all
of that, then things are going to
work. Except that none
of them ever thought about,
oh, we're gonna have to sell this
thing to somebody, don't we?
And so they went for the whole
capacity building part.
And this is, by the way, a lot of
what aid does a lot of what the
world Bank is financing overall, a
lot of what the IMF is financing
because frankly, that's all they can
finance financing
buildings maybe, or even training.
That's fine. You can finance that.
But the activity that comes around,
you don't just wake up and say, uh,
you're going to have to focus on
bananas. You're gonna have to focus
on coffee.
That's not how it works.
So in their case, they got all of
their capacity building going.
And then they started looking around
and being like, okay, uh, we have
no business, you know, warehouses
for the hibiscus.
But the women were growing all the
bananas.
We have, um, all everything
is in bags that you can scrape.
And then they're like, well, how
exactly are we going to sell this?
And that's when they reached out to
someone like me, uh, him
and his lieutenants.
And then basically they were
expecting for me to just hand out
decades of my work relationship
buildings, um, going to buyers,
finding out who is buying what, uh,
finding out what customers want,
finding out all of this stuff and
creating a product that matches the
market and all of that.
So they came to me and said,
basically, hand out all of us
relationships, hand out all of
that know how, and that all of that
knowledge because, you know, we're
trying to save Africa, literally.
That's what we're saying. And I'm
like, even then you have no respect
for how the market works, because if
you were talking to another person
that you would like to consult with,
I know you would probably be
proposed to pay them.
I know you would not just expect
them to just hand over their
relationship, the buyer
relationships without maybe
proposing, uh, some type of
contract, maybe 5% of what you do
not know.
But how did you even had with me?
And like, this is an attitude you
have on the market.
No, not. No wonder you go.
No. And so eventually what happened
is they went nowhere and things
started writing all over the place,
all this stuff.
But we spent they spent millions
of dollars on the type of way an
entrepreneur would have probably
produced the same, better quality,
cheaper, and still be able to
sell it. But they had nothing to
show for.
And um, so that's the mentality
of people like that. But then it
doesn't stop there, because what
happens is by the time
I showed up and I was trying
to do, I was working on setting
up a supply chain.
At some point, we looked like we
could look like we like them
because, uh, the first part of a
supply chain is you grow the
hibiscus, you store it, all of that.
But by the time it arrived, a lot of
these women were like, there's no
way we're going to be growing
hibiscus again.
We know your type.
You come from there.
You tell us. It's just a matter of
producing, uh, x, y,
z. And then we work
hard. We spend all of our time doing
it, and in the end, we have nothing
to show for. Look over there.
We still have production from last
year that's rotting in this, in
these warehouses that we built.
So we don't have time for this lady
buy. So I even had to redo,
undo that story and redo it
to get them to even be willing to
quit producing.
So you see, it doesn't stop at what
you did.
Yeah. Um, you talk a lot in
the book. I mean, if there is a
message, it's that what Africa,
you know, what Africa would benefit
from is, you know,
millions of Africans creating
businesses, uh, becoming
entrepreneurial and things like
that. But you, you stress how hard
it is within Africa
to start a business.
Um, can you work a little bit
through. At one point you talk
about, you know, how what it's like
to start a business in Senegal,
your home country, uh, versus,
you know, opening a business
in, say, Houston, Texas or something
like that.
And now we're going to bed.
But, uh, but before I go ahead, um,
before I go there, Nick, allow
me to go back just a little bit to
before. And because that one, I
think it's very important that I try
to nail it here with you because,
uh, despite saying
what what we say, many
people still have a hard time
because, like, how come you
and African be against for who did
how, how, how and even you
know that I say you have to think
the world is life is made of trade
offs, Nick. You know that very well.
But when it comes to foreign aid, I
think people only look at supposedly
the little wins.
Uh, you know, in in betrayed
us. But I want to make
it clear here for people to
understand the trade offs
because it very important.
So I had this woman, she was very
upset with me.
And so that's a reason why I had to
go there.
So for her, like, surely the
roads can be, can only be helpful.
Andre, you know you're not going to
tell me about your for dirt roads
and people are having ways to go
from point A to point B.
And I said, listen lady, I don't.
But still with even with that in
mind, this is why I have a beef with
it. I said, for that road, for
that road, you're seeing the road.
And that's where reason why for you,
we need to continue.
Okay.
Let us let let me tell you what.
That road is really the cost really
of that road. You see road equals
benefit. Let me talk about cost.
Cost number one.
Because of this road,
I have a culture of dependency
that gets but keeps on being
ingrained in my people.
That surely cannot be good
for the entrepreneur mindset.
But I would like to. But what we
need from them in order to really,
uh, create wealth and value,
right? A cultural dependency just
doesn't go hand in hand.
How do how does a road create
dependance?
Okay, I'll tell you how it does.
Because if we have to rely
we we got this road.
This road came because of foreign
aid. Foreign aid came to us because
supposedly we're poor.
Our governments are literally poor.
They don't have enough money to
cater to all the needs of what the
government would need money for
building roads, buildings, schools,
building hospitals, things like
that. That's what people think about
most of the time, building
infrastructure, especially
now, I would like to
tell even people, why do you think
we are in that situation?
Why do you think that we're poor
in the first place so much that we
need you uh, to,
you know, inject the additional cash
so that we can build the roads that
normally we should have built for
ourselves with the money that we
made.
We are poor because we don't let
our entrepreneurs work.
So if you just
come and finance for me
what I should have finance for
myself and by myself,
you and you.
And we keep doing this.
Nothing has changed since the end
of so-called colonialism,
you know, um, nothing
has changed. So for the past 60 some
plus years, our people
seeing this happen regularly,
it means that, you know, you're
building a culture of dependency
because for 60 years, we don't
expect to be building our own roads.
And that's something that I explain,
um, I see often times,
you know, like just you have a day.
I give you an example.
I am about to I just actually
hired him. At first I was almost
like going to back off, but then I
remembered my.
Okay, my God, you're trying to build
the future generation because they
call. So we were
discussing, you know, we were
negotiating, um, uh,
something, um, a contract for
to be part of my social media team.
Right. So this young African all the
way from Nigeria, and then,
um, I send him a message
to, to so basically proposes
a price to me, the price makes
absolutely no sense.
You know, if you in the marketplace,
it makes no sense.
It was way too high for what it was.
He was definitely twice, uh, twice
as more expensive as what it should
have been, at least, if not more.
Then, um, I
say, okay, why don't you go back?
You think about it and you send me a
message. And then he went back and
he sent me a message, and his
message was about, well,
um, and he he gave
me all the reasons why I
should pay him that price, but
none of it had really to do
with the value he was bringing to
the table.
So it was very much about, I
understand, you know, I, I
appreciate I'm going to have
opportunity to apprentice with you
and all that stuff. He was he could
see all the goods he was going to
get from this.
And he also could see that he's
not up to speed with where
I need him to be.
But we're integrating him and we're
just going to keep, keep growing.
But so none of his argument
to me had to do with the value
he was going to bring.
But more this idea of,
you know, my father has been taking
care of, uh, of helping me, even
though I'm a young adult now, he's
22 years old.
I'm young adult now.
Um, and I just would like for him to
finally have some relief and not
have to support me.
I'm an older and the older one in
the family, so it would be nice that
I'm no longer a burden for him.
And also if I'm, uh, under good
conditions and all of that, then it
means that I could do a better work.
It's almost like you coming in
saying I ideally would need
the lifestyle of $100,000
a year, right?
Whatever. What? I'm just a number.
Uh, and I know that I really
should be getting only 5000, but,
you know, if you pay me 100,000,
then, you know, it takes care of
this problem. That problem bespoke
that problem. Then maybe I can do a
good job. And so when I saw that
first, I was like, no.
But when I got back to him and I
said, you know, I really like x x,
x. But an entrepreneur
sort of succeeds because
the everything is based on value.
So while I have a lot of sympathy
for all the things you shared, this
is not the value doesn't match up
with what you're going to bring.
But you see.
You would not see.
I talked to many
people in the US and in some parts
of a developing world where, you
know, people don't expect, you know,
handouts or much and
they don't talk about things the
same way. You know what I mean?
So but the fact that so many of us,
this is how we justify
what you know, how we justify what
we want to earn.
That's wrong.
And it goes back to that cultural
dependency I was talking about to a
perfectly happy saying, I need this
and give it to me.
And also when they deal with me
thinking, oh, this wealthy person
that you can just get whatever from.
So the dependency goes
all the way down to me today, trying
to do a contract with this person
and having been there to say,
no, we're not going to rely on
people's goodwill.
So that's one of number one
currency.
Number two.
So for that road, I guess a
generation of young people
behaving this way which cannot
operate in the market.
I go back for that road.
I also got, um,
more violence and,
uh, more violence, as well as,
uh, leaders who never want to leave.
And usually throughout the violence.
Let me explain myself.
Foreign aid represents
trillions of dollars that have been
spent on this continent since the
end of so-called, um, communism.
So since the beginning of the, in
the late 50s, early 60s.
That's what's been going on.
And look
around you.
You have people who have been around
for more than 20 years, some of them
almost 40 years.
I think I think Togo is the guy who
has the longest standing out there.
But anyway, so what happens here is
what do you know what they're
fighting for? Do you really think
that they're fighting for the
little peanuts?
But ah, but we are, you know, paying
them in, in the ways of taxes.
Because when you have so few laws
and so few, um, you know, employees,
official ones, so what they're
fighting for, really, at the end of
the day, is control,
control for access
to, um, the natural resources.
They control the fighting for
control to access to this foreign
aid, especially about
foreign aid, the fighting for
that. So the more foreign aid you
provide, the less these people
have an incentive to actually let
their wealth creators work.
And most importantly, the more
you're incentivizing them to not
even want to leave and not
wanting to leave will also
lead to, uh,
violence.
That to me, that correlation is very
direct. And you would have to be
brilliant to not see it.
So for that road, I'm getting a
price and it's going to stay there
forever, despite not doing just.
And I'm also going to get violence
erupting because everybody's
fighting each other in order to
control that.
But pile of pile of money.
So that's number two.
That violence.
And, um.
Last but not least.
You are standing on.
Us actually never getting there.
You you're you're proposing what
we're going through right now.
These, uh, there is no incentive
in getting the business environment
right, so that our business,
a wealth creators, can create.
Because if they can create, if
our inntrepreneur is actually freed
to enterprise, which is the
environment. But the only thing we
ask from government is an enabling
environment.
What's your incentives to put it in
place?
They put it in place.
It means the poverty is gone.
It means before it dries out.
So I ask you
if for in exchange for road on
top of. That's going to be a crappy
road.
And if it's a bridge maybe ten years
from now, if a bridge is going to
collapse, some of us are going to be
dead on it. But who is going to go
after the CCP funded
company but got the business that
got to do in the first place?
No. We're dead. Nobody cares.
A road we paid for ended up costing
us five times more than what it was
supposed to cost because of all
types of, you know, um, um,
corruption as we know.
And so for that crappy road of
yours.
I get the cultural dependency that's
going to follow my youth?
Um, you know, generation after
generation. So we're talking long
term for but crappy road of yours.
I'm going to get violence.
And also people who do not want to
even move in a doing a good job
for but crappy, uh, road
of yours. I'm going to get,
uh, another generation of
entrepreneurs who are denied
their right to enterprise,
which will lift the country out of
poverty. So all of a sudden, does
that road does that foreign aid?
Uh, you know, is is it
does it all of a sudden you
yeah.
You, you know, you, uh, talk
about how, uh, you're, uh, you're
obviously no fan of colonialism
and imperialism, you know, as it
existed in the 19th, in the first
half of the 20th century.
But then you talk about a kind of
neo colonialism that is coming
through foreign aid, that empowers
governments that are not
in the business of, you know, uh,
promoting their people,
but rather in taking as much money
as they can from the West and things
like that.
One of the things that you point
out, and there's a really deep
and and horrible irony here,
is that one of the most successful
exports to Africa from the West is
essentially socialism or,
uh, kind of top down structure
where the government is, you know,
picking it beyond picking winners
and losers, it's really controlling
access to all sorts of things.
Can you talk about the persistence
of, if not pure socialism,
then a kind of socialist
mentality where a few
people kind of call
all the shots?
Um, you know, where does that come
from? And how do you confront
that in 21st century
Africa?
Yes. So
when I started to connect the dots,
as I'm trying to, as I explained in
the book as to how prosperity
actually is built, because,
you know, also another thing is
I think many people forget that, uh,
poverty is the natural state of man,
man as a humanity.
But in any case, um, when you ask
yourself, how is prosperity built?
And eventually you start to connect
the dots? Me? In my case, being an
entrepreneur doing business on both
sides of a world is really what
opened my eyes to this whole
issue around, um, around
a really rotten business environment
that many African nations offer
their citizens and into ponerse.
Um, so there,
when I discovered that I was,
I was blown away.
I was just really blown away when,
when I, when I made the
when I connected the dots between
the fact that. Wait, if you
make it hard for you entrepreneurs
to enterprise, of course we're not
going to build the wealth and
prosperity that goes with it.
And of course, you're not going to
have a sovereignty that goes with
being a prosperous nation.
Conversely, if you make it easy for
you entrepreneurs to enterprise, we
build wealth, you know, um,
prosperity and then people
your country is is prosperous,
meaning it matters in the
grand scheme of things in this it's
called the world.
And when I understood that, it was
like, wait, so then why?
Why do we have such an environment?
I mean, did we just wake up?
And it was this way, what happened
to us?
Uh, how we just all we just
as crazy as some people claim we
are or we.
There's some people claim we are,
but we would not, you know, know
what what it takes and do it.
And then that's when I started to
stumble upon the work of someone
like George, Utah.
Because Georgia, you do the missing
piece for me and
Nick, when I started reading from
George, that's when I made a
realization, even myself.
I realized back then that
as an African who who
profoundly cared about Africa, even
I for me, the story
of Africa started
with slavery.
From there moved on to really
awesome and then to present day.
But it never occurred to me,
uh, to even, first of all think
about Africa pre
slavery time, let alone
think about what type of, um,
you know, economic systems were
being ran in different parts of the
continent, all of that.
It's when I read from George, but
I was like, wait, wait, wait.
These people have been around for a
long time before that time.
But the world, the rest of world
seems to have established as
the starting point for African
history.
And I realize to this day
many people black,
non-Black, African and African.
For many people, unconsciously the
story of Africa and black people
starts with slavery.
Mhm. And George George was
amazing in the sense that
he looked in a different direction.
And so not only he looked very he
was curious about that, but then
what he had uncovered and what the
research is uncovering more and
more.
He said men before
the white men ever set foot on the
continent, they're a
free, free, free enterprise,
you know, very people were free.
And then people were like, well,
what are you talking about to.
No, no, no. Go back and research all
of us. And then even research will
work with people like, um, Jamal,
you know, Kenyatta, the first, uh,
leader of Kenya.
So what all of this is showing
you is even there when people
thought. But Africans don't, uh,
have the same, um, you know,
relationship to private property, to
property rights.
Kenyatta is showing in his books
why that was just like
a make up of the West of
a Western person who doesn't
understand when he goes on.
Because he would tell you in his
book, Facing Mount Kenya, every
single piece of land.
You ask the African, you say, whose
land is it will say ours.
But what do you mean by always what
you think? Because.
And he says, every single plot of
land could be traced directly
to the person he belongs to, the
family belongs to, or the clinic
goes to. Every time we're talking
about private ownership
of the land and and you see
and but something like that was
misconstrued and it was been ways
for Western today.
Aha. We told you Africans are
socialist and the Africans left.
More on that with the ubuntu concept
I am because we are.
And so that's what someone like
neuro Ray of Tanzania, for example,
leaned on to say, yes,
this is we are socialist as well
and the African social is one
too. So we conflated two things that
had nothing to do with each other.
The way Africans live as a social
fabric. We're very you.
We're socialist in our social
fabric.
But how we used to make
our money, we were as capitalist as
anybody else, right?
But capitalist you're just I mean,
you're essentially just talking
about kind of voluntary market
transaction markets.
Exactly. Free market
entrepreneurialism.
So so what happened there is so
now you go back because my question
was why?
Why are we doing this today?
What happened to us.
And then what happened is what
George put his finger on
that critical, pivotal moment
in our life, in our history as
Africans, as to where we are to
where we are today, economically
speaking.
So basically what happened was
during the end of the 50s, early
60s, uh, you know, it, um,
um, Nick, you
were the height of the ideological
battle, uh, as represented to what
ended by Babel West fighting
for freedom and practicing
capitalism as its economic system,
free markets, and then facing off
with the East, various forms of
statism.
It is during that time we were
just, um, are some some of the
people who would be the liberators
of Africa, meaning the people
who would go on to also be the first
presidents of these nations.
They, um, during
that, um, battle of ideologies
that was going on both sides
looking for influence, usually
looking south to the middle South.
We you can very easily understand
what happened.
And it is what happened basically,
um, the Marxist socialists at the
time. But first of all, it was the
fury of Vogue.
You would have to have been crazy
to believe that Marxist socialism
did not work, because we were still
in the middle of allies coming from
the, you know, Soviet Union about,
you know, um, their
crops still working.
So, um, our side
said our Africans
basically, um, they said,
look, the West is who
enslaved us.
Well, colonialism, uh, surely
whatever we are promoting, we're
going to be against.
And on top of that, you Marxists
are the ones who traditionally have
been fighting for racial justice,
which is very true, which is very
true.
You know, for all my criticism of
these guys, minus Marx
himself, it was a racist.
But Marx says many there
were many well-meaning Marxist
people who actually believed in
racial justice.
And so between those combinations
and the forces of the time and
just where most intellectuals were
back into back in the times, yeah,
many of these people, uh, embraced
the, um, the Marxist socialism
ideologies of their time.
And that's how Africa,
as most of a continent was going to
become free
and starting the independencies
it started with basically leaders
who have been infected
with the disease.
But market socialism ideology is
and that's how we got to where we
are today. Because, by the way,
that heritage
has never been
questioned again, ever.
And when the book is trying to do is
for us to question but legacy.
Yeah, that this question we need to
question the legacy of Thomas
Sankara.
We need to to, uh, to, um,
look at the legacy of people like
Julius Nyerere, Ray, all of them.
We have to look at the legacy and be
able to say, yes, I
completely understand where you came
from, a complete genius in where you
came from. I can even understand the
emotional state in which you were,
and I can even forgive you
for having gone that path.
But 60 some plus years later,
with everything that we know,
we ever follow the Berlin Wall and
everything with the war has given us
the latest in them being China,
being able to rise to prosperity
thanks to the free markets from the
East.
We have no more
excuse for not,
you know, challenging the legacy
of, um, of that time.
Let's talk about the present
reality. I mean, one of the most
stunning parts of the book is
when you, you discuss
the the difficulties of starting
a business in your home country.
Can you explain to
people you know, it's like it's
never easy to start a business in
the first place, because you have no
idea if it's going to work.
You got to get, you know, capital or
partners and things like that.
But what makes it so hard?
What are the steps that make it
really tough in Senegal to,
you know, start working?
Yeah. So basically, um.
Like you said, your heart starts
running. Starting and running a
business anywhere is hard enough,
but just the nature of business.
It's heart. That's why there's only
a few part of a population but our
business. Maybe there's a nurse, but
there's a reason why
most of us are just happy doing
our own thing, having a job.
And you know, we don't want to have
to think about how to make payroll.
Um. So so we have those
added we have the normal
difficulties of doing business
because I'm not I'm not crying about
it. It's it's my choice.
We all know it's hard.
It's yet my choice.
So I'm not going to cry for that.
And I actually welcome the
challenges, but it makes life more
fun.
But the problem you have in Africa,
in many African nations,
is that you have these added,
um, unnecessary hurdles
that are completely manmade.
I wish I knew ten years in this way
government made.
So let me try to explain to people
what this means.
Because when I have
sometimes arguments with, uh,
friends of mine who are fellow
Bernie Sanders, you know, supporters
and the like, I, you know, like, uh,
um, what do you call it?
The Scandinavian nations are a
model. And I said to them then,
okay, great.
When do you believe that you should
be as easy for any entrepreneur in
Scandinavia to do business as it is
for any entrepreneur in Africa?
Do you believe it should be?
Yes, I do.
Okay, so then we've got a problem
because Scandinavia is more
capitalist than most African
nations. Okay.
So then it's like, wait, what?
What do you mean? Okay, this is what
I mean. What I mean is.
Nick.
When do us.
Uh. And I told you I have a sister
company here, and this is a company
in Senegal.
That's all. All my business I have
in common. So I'm very much front
seat to look at the discrepancy
between the ease of doing business
on both sides, and then to realize
that one in Senegal is not just, uh,
an anecdote. It's not just Senegal,
but it's like that. It's pretty much
the whole continent. And this is
why, by the way, you always hear me
saying Africa. And then my friends
are like, and Africa, Africa's
54 countries.
I'm like, yeah, you know better than
I do. But anyway, keep on scrolling.
At the end of the day, however,
even though we're 54 nations
when it comes to our business
environment, we very much start to
look like a village. So yes, I'm
going to keep saying, okay,
so when it comes to, um,
to that, what does it mean?
Uh, the business in the US,
Nick and my gut need to get into
an employment contract.
Nick is going to be a great lab
technician, and it's
all great. We negotiate the price,
but works for you, but works for me.
As you know, when we go to, we're
going to work.
We? I send you a contract, you sign
it, I sign it, put it in my app, I
put in my drawings, put it in your
drawer, in your. In your cloud.
Whatever.
We now we move on to work
every, uh, every two weeks.
I can, you know, your your pay comes
directly into your bank account.
We have set up everything
now.
And all of this, by the way, happens
quickly, right?
I mean, you send me the contract,
send me your bank information.
Everything is good to go now.
We're in Senegal.
Nick and I want to get into the same
contract.
Well, we're going to have to print
it. Print it?
Physical copies in three.
You sign. I signed all of them.
Then I or my
CPA and I better hire a CPA,
because if you try to do it by
yourself, you're going to make
mistakes because the labor laws are
so complicated that you
should hire an expert in
order to not make a mistake.
Because if you make a mistake, it
means you might be harassed,
your employee might come after you
for various things as well as a
state. So you don't want to make
mistakes on that.
So you have to hire somebody, which
means extra cost.
So I hired my CPA,
CPA, he's in the capital city
because that's usually where a lot
of the good people are, because
everybody's concentrated in the
capital city, because all the
government offices are concentrated
there as well. That's how you have
one capital city, where you have one
quarter of a population living in
and living like sardines and all the
other, you know, anyway,
so three,
three.
One. So I have now next.
My next step is I'm going to have to
go. Physically you'll
be like 2023.
Why do you have to go?
Because our government, our
government officials do not look at
emails. If you don't email them
something, you might as well imagine
it was lost in the mail for
real.
So you get yourself in
a car.
In our case, we are in the middle
of nowhere. We're in a little
village, and I did that on purpose
because my whole thing is I'm not
going to do it like everybody else
and go into crowded capital city
where 25% of a population is.
We need to give people a chance to
stay in their communities and
build, you know, a life.
But the way that's going to happen,
you have to anchor it with two
things. But the first thing is a
job, and then we also anchor it.
The second thing is school because
we have a school for the children of
the workers.
So but I did this.
It was my goal. My goal was I want
to do it reverse so people get
a chance to stay home in their
communities and build and
not do what my parents did.
But at the national level, my
parents left me behind to migrate to
abroad.
In this case, many parents leave
their kids behind to migrate to a
big city.
So as a little girl, you still have
the same problem. Where's mom?
Where's daddy?
That's not that's not funny.
So I and so
and I think Nick best story has been
what's followed me my whole life.
My whole life. I do not want for
other kids to have to be separated
from their parents or their
grandma. Because later I had to
leave my grandma, uh, just because
of economic reasons.
No child should have to go through
that. If we can have if the adults
can afford it can work and avoid it.
And so I really
did what I believe that.
And so I went to these, uh,
communities and built bear.
And so what it means is
okay, but the problem is I have
to go, uh, once we sign these
documents, we have to go to
what we call aspects.
So labor inspection office,
a government office.
Um, we're lucky
because we don't have to go to a
capital city in this case, which is
a good two, three hours away.
Um, in this case, it looks like
there is a regional antenna, but
still an hour away and
an hour and a half.
And how bad the roads are.
Bad day.
And it's usually be to an hour, hour
and a half. So I have to drive
there. So we leave first thing in
the morning to be there.
We arrive. So basically what it is,
is once you arrive there, some
government official who does
not even know
where you where you guys are
operating from.
He does. He has never built a
business in his life.
His life?
He knows nothing about our industry.
He knows nothing, nothing,
nothing about anything.
But this person will get to decide
if you and I indeed can work
together.
After we have said we want to work
together and we signed the
documents.
So and so, this person show up at
the office.
Uh, you're there for 8:00 even
before eight, because it opens at
eight. So you were before.
So you can leave your first one and
go back because you've got you've
got a business to run.
Nine. Nobody.
Ten. No one.
11. No. One.
Noon. Where is it?
Running errands. Personal errands.
And there's absolutely nothing that
I can do about it, even though the
guy's there to serve me.
Remember government officials.
And everybody shuts up.
Because if you start to show that
you're upset or even frustrated or
guess what? It's going to take you
longer because they know how
to make you pay for your,
you know, your your attitude because
that's how they call it.
So if a guy shows up and in this
case you said, well, where
is, um, Nick's health
certificate?
I'm like, wait, what?
And here I had hired a CPA
to handle all of it.
He's the one who handled the
contracts
everything and told me every single
step. But I need to go through.
So it's done right.
And I arrive, and the guy tells me
about a piece of paper was
in the law, but I've.
But my my CPA didn't send me.
And I call this again.
Like he's saying I need an expert
document and I'm and he's like, what
are you talking about? And so he
talks to him. And the guy said,
well, it's in there, but we have
to have our health certificate to
make sure that, uh, Nick is
physically up to do this job.
And so we didn't know about that.
So now he's like, well,
uh, but, you know, that's what they
like, but you that there is a
law and there's so many of them.
Of course there are some you are not
going to know and then you don't
know about it. And now I could see
in his eyes, his eyes were sparkling
because you know what? He was now
with a bribe.
Mhm. Because think about it.
I'm this empty preneur.
I've got so much to do.
I left my company early in the
morning, cut on my sleep,
got in early in the morning, waited
until noon.
Finally he's there.
But he's telling me. But my file is
missing something and it
means I'm going to have to start
over all over again.
But guess what?
Most people do exactly what's.
What's what.
What is coming next?
You give a little something and
it all of a sudden. Okay, fine.
I don't need the fine.
You can go.
So in my case, I said I am not
going to do that because I don't
give bribes. Because especially if I
step forward, I said I prosper means
good because I get to see all the
problems. Yeah.
So I go back, I go back, I send
you to a doctor who doesn't even
look at you.
This is a rent seeking spring as
well. It's in the laws.
And so he writes you a thing.
Never looked at you, didn't measure
nothing, and you come back with
people. I go back now.
He's allowing me for 60% of
the files that I brought to be, uh,
to go through.
But then there's a few that don't go
through because he said, uh, this
guy, he's going to have to be a
night, a night guard in your in your
company. And, uh, sorry,
but the convention says nothing of
that for that type of company, that
type of industry.
Like. Wait, what?
So because what thing
is in Senegal, every single job
is, uh, in a convention is part of
a corpse.
You know, uh, he's corp, whatever it
corp with the government.
This is very civil law style.
Right. And this is also what the law
of common law.
So in this case, that's what it is.
And so, Nick, after months
of going back and forth, I was
able to finally hire some of these
employees if I wanted to do it the
legal way.
Right. And so just level, that's
what it is when the people I hired,
how do I pay them?
Normally should be a bank account,
but guess what?
Uh. Another one.
Majority of people are unbanked.
Where are the unbanked?
Because some of my employees, you
know, they don't even have, um,
IDs. Proper IDs.
If you don't have a proper ID, you
can imagine you can't even open a
bank account.
And even if you open an account when
you have certain salaries, if your
salary is just, you know, good
enough for you to take care of your
family and everything, and the bank
wants to function a good amount
from it every single month.
But makes no sense.
So I am working with my employees to
find out. First of all, how can we
have you be able to receive money
in a different form, but just cash?
Because also I can't just keep them
cash because otherwise I can't get
my accounting record straight, which
means they're going to come after me.
What are you, uh.
You know what that money laundering
are you doing? Who knows what else?
So I have to show things that are
official.
They are not official.
You can't really.
You know, you shouldn't really try
to get to force them into having
this bank account. But even if they
have, it's going to cost them a lot
because the banking systems are the
most regulated in Africa, which
means also among the most costly.
So we eventually there
we had to rely on crypto in order
just to have a money move, because
sometimes you would try.
So at first how is paying people?
So one person who has nothing to do
with our company has a bank account.
I would wire money from us to
that person.
And then that person disperses
it by making everybody sign.
So we have a record. That money went
from each of these to the one
day this person I'm trying to send
in money and after two weeks
wire, after two weeks,
we don't know where the money is.
And eventually after four weeks, the
money gets returned
and that goes to return.
And then I try to do it through
Western Union after a few,
um, you know, for a short time it
worked, but all of a sudden I get a
call from the compliance office from
Western Union after the money left
to say there is a problem.
Uh, we need to know who you're
sending this money to. You know, the
whole KYC thing.
No. You're right.
And so, um, so I
had to answer, who are these people?
How do I know them?
How long have I know them?
What am I doing with them?
Do I have proof of what we're doing?
All of this stuff?
And then, um, finally, um,
we're like, okay, after being
literally feeling like, what's like
an interrogation, uh, like your
type of criminal.
Finally they say, okay, we'll call
you back only two hours later
to say, well, you did not.
We were not satisfied with what you
said. So your money will be
returned.
Uh, you'll get it back in eight
days. Oh, thanks a lot.
My money now is with you.
You did it for eight days, and they
send it back to me.
Meanwhile, I have to think about
what else to do. That's what, in a
way, me got me into crypto.
So when people talk about dough and
saying, oh, it's a scam scheme.
No, you. Because in the West you
look at crypto as an asset class
to and a speculative, you know,
uh, asset class.
Uh, it's more simple than that.
Crypto for us, especially Bitcoin
simply represents basically
the function of currency.
Right. Um, you know, but so we
see that in crypto.
So anyway, so so this is all
the things Nick. Right.
And I layer another thing
that you talk about in the book is
then in places like Senegal
when you are importing
goods that you might need, know if
you if you need a computer, if you
need a car, if you need whatever.
The tariffs are tremendous.
Right. As well as when you're
sending goods out of the country.
Uh, yes. Yes.
Yeah. So for example,
you need a car to come in.
Um, you know, cars
are basically the car is going to
cost you double by the time you're
done with tariffs, literally.
And um, when you
have then you're going to have this
company, you know, that there are,
uh, investment office epics in
this case. There's also, uh, the
promotion is obviously small.
So epics, they literally
they stand for helping, you know,
like assisting in, uh, with
FDI, making it easy for
you to supposedly set up a shop, but
all it is, really is on the
equipment that you're going to need
for your business.
They're going to withhold, uh, the
taxes, but you should have the
terrorist, but you should have paid
on it for at least three years
because, like, yeah, it takes at
least four years to the company to
get up. But it's not like they're
excusing you that they're just
withholding it.
So once you get there, you're gonna
have to pay this thing.
So exactly how did you help me?
It's still going. It's still going
to be the same cost of doing
business. You just delete it.
And so that's number one.
Is, is that kind of set up,
uh, similar throughout Africa
regardless of what countries
might have, uh, you know, what
European countries might have, uh,
been the colonial powers.
Yeah, it is, it is
because, Nick, think about it,
what all of these countries have in
common. Because if you
if you never bothered
to think about liberating
your wealth creators, entrepreneurs,
if you never bothered to liberate
them and you stayed in this madness,
but you inherited from the colonial
times, right?
Of, uh, socialist policies, most
African nations are run with five,
even for the ones that are nuts, but
say, oh no, we're not socialist or
we like Nigeria for example.
Even then or running five year
plan Allah Soviet style, right?
So for the most part, we're still in
the same camp.
Um, so if you don't make
it easy or possible
for you wealth creators to create
and create en masse, then what
happens? You stay poor.
And so what? You're going to have to
rely on your only source of,
uh, budget income as a nation
is going to be the money you get
from foreign aid to supplement
the little that you get from
whatever you get from taxing your
people.
So basically, your whole game
is domestically.
You tax you people to death on
everything, but you can put your
hands on and given, but you don't
produce much on the ground.
Um, you know, you're primarily
relying on, uh, natural resource
extraction.
Yet these are people who live where
people who are going to need
shampoos,
people are going to need to. So
people are going to need, um, cars.
People are going to need, uh, TVs,
refrigerators when they can afford
it. They're going to need all of
that. And you don't produce any of
this crap because you didn't allow
for the market forces to get you
there.
So you basically you're waiting
them. You're waiting them exactly
where, you know, they're going to
show
up and they're going to show up at,
uh, the customs office,
because the stuff is gonna have to
come from outside.
And so basically, your your
strategy for filling up, uh,
the government's coffers is going to
be domestically tariff, tariff,
tariff, tariff and also
taxes, taxes, taxes.
And uh, internationally it's going
to be foreign aid. That's basically
your your revenue plan.
And he.
Follows.
Are you a fan then?
Uh. Uh, a couple of years ago, uh,
the UN helped push through the
African Continental Free Trade
Area, which sought to
minimize tariffs among,
uh, different African countries as
well as coming in. Is that
conceptually a step in the right
direction or is that more
kind of interference?
Yeah. So?
If they really follow through.
It can only be a good thing.
I am a big fan.
Always. Everywhere.
All the time.
A free movement of people, goods,
services and ideas.
Especially ideas.
I'm a big fan, and
insofar as the fcta,
you know, supposedly that's the
goal.
Then of course I rejoice.
But that's where my.
But then I'm cautiously optimistic
because, as we know, um,
these things take forever.
But most importantly and most
scarily, I was
in Ghana.
Um, not not this December,
but last December, and I went
to the offices to the headquarters
of the Fcta in
Accra, and I was
allowed to sit on some meetings.
I don't know why they allowed me,
but I was able to sit on meetings
where you had different, uh,
countries represented around the
table. And actually they were
continuing some of your
conversations. And, Nick, where what
did I discover?
I discovered pretty much, you know,
like how sometimes you get, um,
buy one, get the second one free.
But then you looked at all the
little lines, and technically
it's going to be almost near
impossible to get the second one
free.
Well, that's what this is shipping
out to be.
Uh, basically every single country.
But part of it for now
is actually working on all the
exemptions, but they would like to
put to it.
And then, um, basically,
yes, but not this not
this part of it. Economy.
Yes, but not this.
So by the time we're done
of the increment we expect it was
designed to provide is going to be
almost. No, because everybody is
busy right now putting the little
clauses to still keep it closed.
Mhm.
And so I'm
not holding my breath I am simply
the ref. And and the other thing
about that too is they can
open about all they want.
But if you still don't understand.
The free markets.
If you still don't understand what
an enabling business environment is.
That's just the top of
that list. I see what they're
proposing.
The ground base
of Bishkek has not been kicked yet.
No. And so and I'll give
you an example.
Let's see if it worked.
Let's say they had it and it's
really working.
Um, I can move my goods
and myself from one continent, one
country to another within the
continent, but nothing
else changed.
The labor laws I talked to you about
didn't change the, uh,
the permit, uh, obtained, uh,
how to obtain permits and how long
and how much it cost did not change
the tax code, did not
change. Become more simple to
understand and easy to pay.
Taxes did not change.
Let's say none of us wins what
we call economic freedom.
But cost is a big enemy.
Freedom doesn't get changed.
Then. My gut is just saying, okay,
okay, um, uh,
you know, uh, Mauritania.
Fine. Now, when I buy, uh,
when I buy maybe my shea butter from
you, I don't have to pay
taxes on it.
Uh, but I still have to pay
taxes on a lot of
things that most Africans don't
manufacture today, which still need
to go to my product.
So but the minute that product comes
in anywhere from Africa, it's going
to be taxed from that entry point
and then, you know, went from there,
start travel.
Really, how much easier have you
made it? Have you made it for me?
To do business, and is it going to
be really still enough
for me when I have a chance to build
my business somewhere in Africa or
outside of Africa, to choose Africa?
But the other thing people think
it's just you touch here, you touch
when things get better.
That's why you should not try to
control the market, ever.
Because it's not about touching one
thing here, touching one thing
there. Somehow the market,
the way it works is enough.
It's a it's a it's a critical mass
of things that have to happen
for something halfway across
to make sense.
And that's what it is.
No one can really guess
that so many people are free to
do so.
Now let's talk a little bit about
how you affect change, you know,
within Africa and other parts of the
country, because there are other
parts of the world.
Um, you know, you mentioned Bitcoin
as a way of routing around certain,
you know, uh, uh, kind
of bottlenecks in the economy and
things like that.
You, uh, talk about startup
cities. Um, yes.
Yeah. How how would startup cities
explain what those are and how that
would help in an African context?
Yes. So in so
far as Africa is the
most, is the poorest region in the
region in the world because it
happens to be the most overregulated
region in the world.
It's a region in the world where
entrepreneurs lack what
entrepreneurs need the most, which
is an enabling business environment.
Right now,
most of these countries, you can
imagine there are people already
benefiting from the status quo,
right?
And you can therefore, and you
also can appreciate, I'm
sure, your audience as much as the
next person.
How cumbersome and complicated
and hard and long
it takes to do piecemeal legislation
and also reforms.
We can all appreciate how
complicated that is.
Costly. Timely.
Everything.
Meanwhile, I'm sitting there and
thinking, while all of that is good,
in the absence of nothing else, we
got to accelerate this.
We got to accelerate.
And most importantly, we have to be
a little bit more radical because
like we said, you and I are tweaking
something here. Tweaking something
there is just not going to get us
there. We have to.
It's the house in such a bad
shape.
But we have to do you do Tabula Rasa
and just start over.
But now, are you really
going to be telling a whole country?
We're going to. We're going to.
We're going to go from one day to
another. Do that.
I'm not going to do that.
So the idea instead is,
how about, uh, we
try to clean up, um, clean
up one, one place at a time.
So the all the startup cities are
is these are next generation,
uh, special economic zones with the
UN law, the UN governance,
especially when it comes to
commercial law.
Right. And, uh, usually based on
commercial law, uh, on, um, on
a common law.
So in any case, that's really for
me what the solution is going to be,
because what you're doing all of a
sudden, you're, you're saying to
these African entrepreneurs who are
trapped in stupid,
dysfunctional, you
know, systems we're in right now,
you're giving them a chance.
You basically given one chance you
have straight from home,
um, zones
that are among the best
business but have among the best
business environments in the world,
and a Singapore or a Denmark
or better.
Right. And you mentioned China
took advantage of special economic
zones. You talked about this in the
book where, you know, in the midst
of a, you know, openly
communist country, they were like,
okay, we're going to create a
sandbox here where entrepreneurs
or business interests are able to
act much more freely than they would
anywhere else in the country.
Exactly, exactly.
So China did that.
SEC.
Uh, by sec.
Me, I would call each of us.
SEC is a startup city, right?
And, um, before China,
places like Singapore have done it,
but more at a nation state level
because they're small enough, but
they can do it all country.
Uh, but if you're big, uh, as
China is, you can do it zone
by zone or Startup city by startup
City. And it still works.
So that's pretty much, um,
you know, looking at that.
Um, but you know, what.
Is in what is in it, say,
in Senegal?
What would be in it for the
government of Senegal to say, like,
okay, we're going to we're going to
let you have this zone
of freedom, which is probably
going to very quickly kind of
outperform the rest
of the country, etc..
Like how do you how do you get the
the incumbents, the people who
benefit from the status quo to allow
that kind of experimentation?
You know, so first of all, um,
it's a very good question.
So I've been I've been on this
path, uh, for the past, um,
more than a year ago.
I started more than a year ago,
being on this path of selling these
ideas to African governments.
When I started, uh, we only had one
African government that really seems
to have understood and be on board.
Everybody else was like, whatever.
You know, we're doing the the zones
like 80 style zones, you know,
special economic zones and everybody
wondering why it's not working.
But I'm like, hello, you're running
an 80s software.
Uh, when there is a, when where's
a premium when this needs
a premium software.
But anyway, continue on.
So what's I think people need to
understand on this, um, Nick,
and why I'm so bullish on the future
of Africa is because we don't need
all 54 nations to go
for this all at once.
All I need is one nation
where you have a leader
who is thinking a little bit more
different than the others, and also
has different goals than the others,
because not all of them are as
corrupt as we think they are.
And even if they do things that are
corrupt, not all of them given
a chance want to, uh, stay
in this state of, uh, of
misery and despair.
And so here what you do,
uh, you need to find a leader
like that, first of all.
So when you're saying, how do you
get somebody to what's in
it for them?
Um, for a leader.
What's what is in it for them?
Doing a startup city is is for
a leader who, deep down knows that
I want to leave a better legacy
behind. And I know that we need
to create jobs. We need to do all of
that. So you start with a leader
like that, that's what's going to be
in there for them.
Then what you do is you make it easy
for this leader. That's why startup
cities matter.
That's why we don't want to do it.
You don't want to do it at the
country
level, because that leader, even
if he or she wants to see there's
something like this thrive,
uh, she or he is going to be limited
because you're many,
many entrenched interests already
exist. And you might be a
COO might happen on you or,
I mean, depending on which
sensitivities or, um,
all of your oligarchs or people who
benefit from the current system,
uh, might become your enemies from
one day to another.
Make sure you don't get elected the
next time. Or who knows your party.
Who knows? So based all of these
realities to deal with and frankly,
also.
Many people, the peoples
of a country might not be
on board, not because they don't
want to be more prosperous, but
because, you know, people are
concerned.
What is that?
How does it work?
You mean now I have to do this?
Um, you know, change.
People don't like change, even if
it's sometimes, you know, how
everybody has with.
Back in the Facebook days.
Every time Facebook changes
something, we all hate it, right?
We're all done.
But then we're like, we love it so
much. Like bees. Never.
But left to our own devices.
But we never would have voted if we
voted for it. We would have said no.
So this reality is very true as
well. So this is why we sort of
cities what I like about it, it's a
way for bees leaders to actually
get their get their cake and eat it
too. So continue doing whatever it
is that you're doing over here.
But over here, let's do an
experiment that doesn't affect
anybody because it's a it's an
area that's rabbit unoccupied.
So we're not feeding people anything
like that.
And in there let's say, okay, what
would happen if a commercial rules.
Because that's the other thing here,
right? I want to insist on that
because I know there are many
stories out there and things
that really delay the adoption of
this, which is like, oh,
it's a country within a country.
No, it's just like, if
China is able to do something like
this, you it should give you
everything you need to understand
that there is no sovereignty being
being attacked.
Uh, your your, your family laws
remain the same.
Your, um, immigration law remain
the same is criminal law.
All of that stuff remain the same.
You're just saying, when it comes to
prosperity building, entrepreneurs
need an enabling environment.
So we're going to look at the
commercial laws especially, and make
sure we give them the best, uh,
environment for them to create.
That's really it.
So, so in an area like that,
you are basically, uh, making
it an opt in type of situation and
virtually everything. You don't
exclude the other people
in the country to come in.
It's not about that.
It's just like there's an extra
option for anybody who wants
to be able to run better businesses.
And that's really all it is.
And so what we have found is
now we're talking to four countries,
four. And I'm very confident,
but very few. Uh, in a very few
months we'll be able to announce,
um, the first one we picked
because now we're competing a little
bit with each other.
But, um, so what's in it for
someone, for a leader
who really has the heart and a mind
in the right place?
Because not everybody is as bad as
they look.
Um, it's going to be legacy.
It's going to be try before you buy
because we're just trying over here.
If it works, it's great.
If it doesn't work, we tried
three more you can do.
So that's what initially to like.
But if it works, probably his
whole country is going to ask
to switch over.
And then the change would have
happened in a rather
quick manner. It would have happened
in a rather, uh, an disruptive
manner, and it would have happened
in a way where the people, actually
other ones at some point say, yes,
we want this to be everywhere.
And when we get to that,
then you see the change
effect started to happen to other
countries. The other countries are
not going to sit there, other of
citizens. Certainly.
I'm not going to say why we're not
doing the same. And then that's it.
That's it. When, when, when I can
type happy and go.
Let's, uh, talk about skin is skin.
This is a company that you started
a few years ago, and and it,
um, makes, uh, skin and
lip, uh, balms or treatments.
Um, how what is skin?
A skin is and how does it exemplify
what you're hoping to, you know,
kickstart all throughout African
entrepreneurship and, uh,
you know, in global enterprise.
Yeah. So what's kinase?
Kinase is basically um it's
manufacturing.
It's African products made
in Africa by Africans.
Uh, very much, you know, for the
longest time especially, um,
you know, there is this movie
Poverty Inc that was documented.
It was very, very, very effective.
I think it helped a lot of people
understand the the traverses
of aid and even NGOs
trying to help, but yet
not helping as much as we as
we as we were thinking that we're
helping.
So we're skin is can really
at the end of a day.
Um, Nick
you're getting a great, uh, great
skin treatments and, uh, lip balms
from us, but me
pretty much I'm in it for the jobs
created. My goal is 2.5
billion prosperous Africans by
2050. That's my goal.
And the way that's going to happen
is as many jobs being created as
possible, which means as many
inntrepreneur is being allowed to
enterprise as possible.
And I offer myself
as exhibit A or, you know,
um, put your foot where your mouth
is. Um, don't just preach to people,
but also practice what you preach.
I'm a very big fan of them, big on
that, and on the concept of
criticize by creating so
but you and so what we're doing
is we're pushing this whole concept
of cheetah made.
So cheetah made, the best way to
think about it is when, um,
you know, Japan managed, you have
made in Japan.
Uh, France made it.
France, um, made in Italy.
When you hear that, it means
a lot of things. It means superb
craftsmanship means quality, it
means premium.
And it. And so you buying from these
people not because you feel sorry
for them, but you're buying for
Mexico because of what?
Into you. So in this case, this
was um, companies
like, um, like skinny skin and
making it in Africa and,
but you can make, um, you know,
movement where, where the cheetah
made a label we're pushing.
All of that was my way of
criticizing by creating towards,
um, initiative.
Like Tom shoes, Toms shoes
believed that the way you
help poor people
is by leaving, giving them shoes
because they could not afford to buy
shoes.
And then that whole thing of buy
one, give one model worked
so well, you know, you buy one
if one parent to a child in need
because probably lives in poverty.
Uh, it works so well that
everybody in their mothers, about
any company around started doing
the same thing socks.
So everything but people miss
to understand is when you shipping
this, uh, your free stuff to
these countries.
We live in communities.
We live in a village.
We live in those businesses.
And who can compete against free,
right? And the village where
we make our skincare products.
It's one of the villages in Senegal
with the most shoemakers in
the country.
We have a few hundred shoemakers,
each one of them hiring at least 15
something people, an average, but
a lot of people now.
But David, shoe the shoe.
Uh, the top shoes truck shows up.
What do you think happens to all of
these people? What do you think
happens to the ghetto?
Like I'm not born. I mean, people
who are buying it, I. I'm not buying
them over here. We have free shoes.
Right? So we destroyed these
jobs. So to me,
it was just like, how can people,
like, see this? I understand the
first instead of thinking you're
helping, but this is not helping.
But it was. It's one thing to sell
people. It's not working in ways of
working, but maybe give them a
chance to participate.
Because when somebody is buying a
Toms.
Yeah.
Oh no, I get that.
And so I guess, you know a question.
You in the book, you discuss a bit,
uh, John Mackey, the co-founder
of Whole Foods, who is, uh,
or the, you know, emeritus, uh,
chairman, co-founder of of Whole
Foods. Foods talked about conscious
capitalism, where he believes that
capitalism has moved beyond or
should move beyond, uh,
kind of the arguments of Milton
Friedman explicitly was making in
the early 70s that, um,
you know, that the own only
responsibility of a company
is to the bottom line of its
shareholders to increase investor
value.
And he says, you know, that that's
not quite right.
You participate in that.
And so with something like
skin is skin, um,
how much is it
you create a product which
can stand alone, you
know, that is a really good product
that is sold at a price that
it can command.
And then how do you factor in like
there is a mission there and people,
you know, and I think John is
absolutely correct about this.
Lots of people are
willing to, you know, part of what
goes into the price they're willing
to pay is the larger
sensibility or mission of a company.
Um, you know, with
skin and skin products, how much of
it is like, okay, this product,
if you didn't know, you know, if it
didn't have a wrapper on it or
something like that, would people
still be buying it?
How much of it is joining
a movement through your consumption
patterns and things like that?
And could you talk a little bit
about, um, you
know, how that plays into the, uh,
uh, the mission that you're pursuing
here?
Right?
Okay. So, Nick, I think the
best way to, uh.
And maybe I'm just going to, um, uh,
for people listening, because I do
know that, uh, maybe some of your
audience might be biased against the
concept. Some, because I see it all
the time. I just came back from a
conference in London when,
uh, people on stage were completely
bashing conscious capitalism,
not understanding what I think.
Um, I think not understanding what?
So let me maybe just make that
differentiation for people listening
to us, because I think it's
important.
Um, you know, the problem with the
concept of conscious capitalism is
that, um, uh, you
can say the same words, but
depending on where your, where
where are you taking your cues from?
It might mean something very
different.
So I just captured a
lot of, uh, people I know on the
libertarian side really kind of
make fun of it.
And, um, you know, some people
on the conservative side also make
fun of it.
Um, they make fun of
the conscious part of conscious
capitalism when we say conscious
capitalism, and also some of them
flat out have an adverse reaction
to it. And I think for them,
if you're having an adverse reaction
to it because they're understanding,
conscious of capitalism, the way the
philosophers which think of
it and the way we philosophers which
think of conscious cops, is very
different from us.
You know, people like John or me all
call ourselves bleeding, bleeding
heart libertarians. We are people
who came from the left.
Uh, we don't reject, um, the desires
of a lot to see a more fair,
you know, society, a society where,
you know, our weakest are still,
you know, taken into account where
our minorities are not to, to
suffer.
We still believe in those, in those,
in those in those principles of
life. And that's still part of our
philosophy.
So, so.
But the problem is, when so people
like us, we still are.
We are capital still we still
believe in the markets in order to
solve our problems.
Any problem?
Um, but the what the
philosophers understand for them,
um, you know, uh, concept
ism is this concept where, yes,
we're going to use, uh, business
supposedly to tackle, um,
problems, including social problems.
But the way they understand
it is, um,
the state has a say in it
has a say in how the
business is actually going to use
its practices to
actually push for, uh, you
know, a better, a better world.
And, uh, the best way to think of
maybe most people's theory is ESG,
ESG, very much, you know, it's
it's a manifestation of that
viewpoint, which I can understand.
I'm a big, big, um, against,
uh, ESG, um, as we stand.
But, uh, what ESG is trying
to the end goal that is trying
to solve, I am still in board.
I still believe that it's a good
it's a good thing to protect Mother
Earth whenever possible.
As a matter of fact, she's one of
the holders of content conscious
capitalism.
So I still believe in all of that.
But where we differ is
how it works.
The conscious capitalists who who
are more your your philosopher type,
they think the state should have a
role in that.
So the state should a come up with
the issue of the day and
also come up with how it's going to
be taken care how how your business
is going to take care about.
So maybe impose more tariffs,
maybe impose more more licensing,
maybe impose all type of things
supposedly to end on the good,
um, on the good, um,
result of having help solve a
problem where the conscious
capitalist ala John Mackey,
Alan Michael Strong Alami,
by the way, they co-founded, uh,
conscious capsule. Michael and John.
Yes. And and Michael is your
husband.
Michael is my husband for
disclosure.
So the way we all look at this
is it is
we believe that business is the
greatest force for good beyond just
hiring people and all.
That's the greatest force for good.
And we believe that, um,
uh, as a business, uh, and as an
entrepreneur, as somebody, when it
starts a business, we believe that,
um, if you basically.
But we but but it is not
anybody's to decide
on the issue of a day.
You, my God, the entrepreneur, you
Nick the entrepreneur.
You decide what is your
issue of the day if
um. And also a.
Customer, right?
Yeah. Because when you decide, yeah,
that's where it's going, that's
where it's going to come in. The
customer. So but you, you start,
you wake up and you're like, I'm,
I'm fed up with um, the fact
that and this is a great company,
for example, tell it, it's a call.
She's got this business.
Tell everybody out of Arizona, I
believe they basically are very
upset with the fact that, um,
after you have been incarcerated,
you have paid you you just used your
society, you went to jail, you spent
your time, you did your thing.
Especially here.
We focus on women.
And because we've been previously
incarcerated, they come out.
And most of these companies, when
you go in, there's a box you have to
check. Have you been previously
incarcerated?
And then the truth is when and you
have to answer the truth because you
know, you're under oath.
And the truth is most people when
they see that I'm sorry, but
consciously or not, it's
vertical selection.
They pass on you.
That's not fair.
That's not fair. I believe in
redemption. People deserve a second
and a third chance if they show up
for it. But in many cases
it's it's denied to have denied
to them. So here you have a fund of
deliverer. Deliverer who says this
is wrong.
So this person could continue
and maybe doing some policy reform
work at the state level all they
want. That's fine. Maybe they're
doing it. But they said we believe
with business we can get there
faster.
Let us show that there is nothing
wrong with previously incarcerated
people by hiring them,
having a thriving business from it
and all of that, and people who
actually support those values.
And that's the other word value.
So you may talk about profit,
but for us it's about value
maximization.
And of course if you maximize
value it's the profits
will just follow eventually.
It's the timeline that you're
looking at but might be different.
So in this case this company
said we are the owner
of bend. The box is we're not going
to ask.
We're going to bend the box at our
own level. We're not going to wait
for anybody to do this.
And then they did that.
And guess what? We presented this at
Conscious Captive. But we're talking
about what to do because that's what
we do during the summit.
People talk about what their
business, what's their issue of the
day and how they're using the
business to really push the agenda
forward and not wait for anyone.
We're not going to wait for the
state to bend the box.
We're going to do it yourself right
now in business.
And guess what? Now many companies
are buying into bend the box so
that and that's it.
That's a cheetah cheetah
mentality right where you don't
you know, don't wait wait
wait. Let me um, as,
um, we wrap up,
I wanted to ask a question.
We we didn't really get to it.
Uh, but, you know, the life
story that you tell is fascinating.
You were born in Senegal.
Your parents moved to Europe for
economic opportunities.
At a certain point, you were brought
to Germany, then Paris,
uh, and France, and then you came
to the United States.
Um, can you talk
a bit, um,
about what it is like to
be part of a diaspora?
Um, because that is,
you know, many, many people are
part of different diasporas.
There's an African diaspora, there's
an Irish diaspora, which is massive.
There are far more people of Irish
descent living outside of Ireland
than there were in, you know, in the
country in 1841 and things like
that. Um, talk a little bit
about the benefits and the costs
of being part of the diaspora, if
you would.
Will I like to save a diaspora
people? We're in a way.
We're mutants.
We're mutants because.
And we bring good things that we
bring things. But I'm not. Maybe so
good. So basically, you're the best
way to think about diaspora is, um,
think about, you know, um, we
are the ones who actually got to
go and see something else.
Uh, but as.
As what?
As when it is.
Whenever it is the case, it means
that, uh, you're going to mute
some, some, uh, mutation
is going to start to happen, right?
And somehow you're going to come up
with this interesting mix where you
decide what you keep from your
original traditions, rules
and all of that, and you also
surely pick up along the way
from the other, from your host, uh,
nation, your host culture.
Cross-pollination starts to happen,
and it makes for a very,
um, different person.
I'm not going to say it's a person.
It's a it's a worse
off person. It's just a different
person. It mutated sometimes
for better. Sometimes it can be for
worse. It depends.
But, um, that's what we are
because and for me, I
explained it in the book, I think,
um, it's, uh, people who
have been in the diaspora more like,
uh, me we need to
remember that and remember that
we belong. We are basically, um,
a mutant species in a way, if
I can say that, um, because
we cannot claim to be in my case, I
cannot claim to be 100%
Senegalese.
Most. I mean, yeah, I'm 100%
My two parents are from Senegal.
They actually even had the same name
before. I wouldn't be married.
And it's not the same because we
have the same tribe or anything, but
it is what it is.
So you can say I'm at 1%.
What? You know.
Yeah. So in our case,
um, I tried to tell people,
you, you have to remember that and
have, um, the, the humility
of what that means.
And humility doesn't mean that it's
a bad thing, but it's just being
humble to recognize that you're not
100% Senegalese.
You're not 100% French.
In my case, you're not 100%, uh,
American, because I also hold both
citizenships.
I am just something different.
And but most importantly,
my role is to try because
I'm different, because I'm a
mutation between both.
I know my role and my.
My duty becomes to be a bridge, a
bridge maker between two societies,
but might not otherwise understand
each other better.
And my role is to us, whenever
I go back and forth to either sides,
to bring to the other side the
very best of beside, I left behind
that they don't know of it
especially. So that's the role of a
diaspora. That's what being does
means.
That's, uh, for me.
Fascinating. Thank you for that.
Um, what is the Atlas network
and, uh, what do you do for them
to promote or how are
they promoting prosperity in Africa?
Yeah.
So the Atlas network is the largest
organization of free market fintechs
in the world. Um, so everywhere
around the world, you see a free
market thinktank.
There, there.
And what what I love about
Atlas Networks.
So in the in the,
in the freedom movement, my,
my love for them has to do
with the fact that they're the ones
who very much focus on
international issues and, um,
international.
And not to say that, you know,
being focused on the US or Europe is
not a good thing.
Um, being focused on us as a good
thing. That's not what I'm saying,
but but, um, it gets plenty
of support where when they
really made it. But international is
a big, big, big part of what they
do.
Um, so that's my first, um,
my first, uh, you know, vote of
appreciation for, uh, just that
work. The other thing I love about
Atlas Network is, um, that
unlike so many places, they
going back, they don't decide the
issue of a day for them.
It's about where, you know,
about defending the principles of
freedom, understanding that, you
know, it's all to serve human
flourishing. And that's another
thing, too. I feel like with them I
really hear this concept of human
flourishing. They're the ones I'm
telling you. The left has abandoned
us, left has abandoned the poor.
And places like, you know, um,
uh, Atlas Network has not abandoned
us. They're there. And more
importantly, they're working with us
on our own terms.
When Atlas, you know, invests
in a partner, that's what we call
the thinktanks.
But, you know, we work with when
they invest in them.
It's not Atlas imposing
the agenda on them
like it is the case with so
many nonprofits out.
And or the United Nations, the IMF,
the world Bank, organizations.
Especially those guys.
So Atlas says Atlas, basically
somebody from, let's say,
Africa, because the center for
African Prosperity focuses on
Africa. That's where I'm at.
So somebody from Africa
decides to start a think tank or has
a think tank, but they would like to
grow, or they have a
project that they would like, or an
initiative they would like to run
with in different tank.
When they come to us and they say,
this is a, this is this
is our views on this us,
this is our views on prosperity,
on, um, freedom
in um, in my country.
And, um, we believe that,
uh, there is something we can do
about it. Like I'll take for
example, um, uh,
the great link that we have, uh,
with, uh, uh,
the name is escaping me right now,
but, um, it's an organization
that ones we invite, we invest in,
in, um, in Burundi.
And so we came up with one time and
they said, look, um, you know,
women's, uh, property rights are not
being respected.
The best way for it to be to happen
is to have it be part of a
constitution.
So eventually they had
a they had an initiative to make
that happen, and we financed
them.
It was not it was not us saying,
you know, like you have to work on
these issues. They came with your
issue and they came with a plan and
we financed them.
And then, of course, you know, where
we put back and how it worked.
But I think that Nic might be
overlooked by many, but it's
not lost on me because when
you're African, meaning you belong
to you belong to the economically
dominated, uh, part of the
world, uh, it's not lost
on us because when you're
economically weak,
uh, the rest of the world uses it
to actually have you become
a pawn for their own agenda.
Maybe. And you can say maybe that's
wrong because everybody they say
states and nations have no friends.
They only have interests.
So if because of weak, they get to
move their interests further.
The conscious cup is in me might say
it's not smart for you to do it this
way. Have it win, win, win and it
will be better. But not everybody
behave that way.
So this is where we are.
And so we are.
We are being told all the time what
to do. We're being told all the time
what to believe.
Uh, when you look at the energy
situation, it's the same thing.
But West some, some all of a sudden
decides fossil fuels.
No more good. We have to go cold
turkey overnight.
Almost in the, in the, you know,
in the, in the grand scheme of
things.
And um, they're out there trying
to promote, uh, trying to push that
agenda down our throats.
If it was just promoting it, even
then, you could say, fine, but it's
like pushing it literally down a
throat. And if we don't even
buy into it, they will have the
means to enforce it.
Because thousands of miles away,
through the world Bank, through the
IMF, through all of these
organizations, they decide
to actually act on this agenda
by not financing
the, the, the development
of a fossil fuels, um, based
infrastructure.
And they will use
ESG as their,
you know, uh, principled and
philosophy to support all of this
stuff. And so we have absolutely
nothing to say compare about to
China and India, who because
they're doing much better than us
get to tell them off, off, off.
Get out of the way.
We can't.
And even if we tell them get out the
way, two things are going to happen
to us. One is that leaders probably
gonna be in trouble because they'll
find a way to get them in trouble.
And two, they're still going to do
what they want to do.
So my whole thing here is
um, but that's what uh,
so Atlas really, um,
gives a chance to the
partners, but we invest and give
them a chance to set the agenda.
And most importantly, uh, execute
on that agenda.
And I appreciate that very much.
And, um, this
makes me remember something that
I.
I'm really big on these days,
Nick.
Something is going on,
but I don't think we're paying
attention enough to.
And I think I know why we're not
paying attention to this, but let me
tell you what's going on.
And I really would like for the
libertarians to wake up because
I am appalled at how
quiet we have been about this
in a tiny country in Latin America.
Great disaster is about to happen.
So, as you know,
many countries have signed the New
York. You know, the New York Treaty
arbitration, which is all
about we are going to respect
international arbitrations,
meaning we don't export people.
Meaning, you know, when something is
signed, we respect it.
Now, um, as
you can imagine, many, many, um,
Latin American nations are part of
it. You know, Central American
craft, our product craft, um, you
know, the American trade.
Yep. So anyway, so a
country like Honduras has signed
that survey.
Supposed to respect that.
A country like Honduras, and
you could imagine this to be almost
any country in Africa.
And that's a reason why I talk about
it, because to me, it's going to be
very interesting to see how America
decides to settle on this.
So you have
an organization that has done
a startup series there.
Mhm. Prosper.
Right. Okay.
So since the new government
took over.
It seems like their big
plan is to renegade
on.
You know, having signed
such a treaty because
some issues we might have with
Prospero.
But again, regardless, for me, it's
like you signed a deal.
You said you're going to be part of
a New York treaty that is going to
support this.
Now, when you have crazy.
Government is trying to do whatever
we're trying to do.
Me. I'm sitting there and once
again saying governments do
what they do, but the people
stand to suffer.
The people of Honduras
deserve better.
I think I hear it from all of them
saying they want prosperity, because
last time I checked, no one wants to
live continue in poverty.
So when you have a start up
cities, for all the reasons I
explained earlier, what the role
and goal of a lot of cities is, is
to bring, um, you know, the enabling
environment. But businesses aka
wealth creators need in order to
create wealth.
They show up and they're going to do
their work.
And then all of a sudden, because of
ideological reasons, you're going to
say, we don't want to support this.
We're going to and in, in,
in, in doing that, we're actually
going to do something that is
going to renegade on our, um,
on our, um, commitment to the
concept of rule of law.
Right. This is a problem.
And it would if it was
just that side doing it.
Um, the government's there.
You know, there's a reason why our
government, our government there is
there's a reason why our countries
are where we are.
Y'all know why.
So startup cities actually
offer these countries
a chance to still attract
international investors
because they're saying, okay,
on your own.
We we don't really trust what's
going on because you're not offering
the best business environment reason
why you don't want to come, but you
managed to carve out an area where
we can we can do this.
So we're coming.
It would be one thing that you have,
uh, governments who have other
priorities do this to themselves.
But it's another thing to me, Nick.
When you have someone like Senator
Warren.
And I'm using her name, Senator
People like Cori Bush
and people like Bernie Sanders.
Citing.
With.
Um, a government, in this case,
the government of Honduras,
helped by a government like
Venezuela, helped like by
a government like Cuba.
About basically,
Senator Warren said it is okay.
To expropriate.
US investors.
In this case, that's the letter
that she championed.
The US government right now is
telling the Honduran government
it is okay for you
to renegade on
rule of law.
It is okay for you to renegade
on the Treaty of New York that you
signed, and also on the
Dutch, um, you know, terms that you
signed on.
This is a terrible
precedent.
If something like this goes,
it's not just Prospero that suffers
this time. And by the way, we'll go
and do something else somewhere else
with this, this idea, these ideas
are ideas for our time.
It will be done somewhere.
It's just a matter of time and we're
working on it. I'm definitely taking
this to Africa.
But my point is,
we all don't have to be
super smart people to imagine what
something like this will do to the
government of Honduras, even if and
when Oprah is gone.
No one, no one
is going to want to invest in
Honduras anymore.
Meanwhile, we have a same Senator
Warren opening her big mouth,
screaming all over the earth,
her and the the you know,
being saying when it comes
to the immigration issue.
I say, Senator Warren, do you not
know what solves immigration?
Do you not?
Because by doing what you're doing.
Get ready to be
tough for all Hondurans to keep
coming. You think you thought you
had caravans before?
Soon it's going to be.
You know more about
caravans, you know, because if
people are not able to accomplish
prosperity on their land,
people are going to do what people
should do.
I don't blame immigrants
for trying to leave where they are
to go to a better place.
It's not ideal.
It's not recommended.
But my parents had to do it and
many more after them did it and will
continue doing it.
This is what humans do.
Your ancestors did better when they
came to this country.
Many sisters.
Okay, so if Senator Warren.
I think she needs to hear it from
us. We don't want her
synchronicities.
Thank you very much.
We don't want a sanctuary city.
You want the Charter cities?
Yes. Yeah.
We want the stirred up cities.
We want the startup things where
we can thrive, where we can build
a life at home, where we
can check out our babies in the
backyard. You know, get to.
We turn around with events
where grandmas and
grandchild get to
live together and be raised
together.
That's what we want.
Given a chance most of us would not
want and would not need to be at
your choice of the border.
We would not.
We never would.
So, Senator Warren, are you
in for a real deal or not?
And I am calling her out
specifically.
This is. I don't even know what to
it. I'm just so.
I'm so sad when I'm not upset.
I'm very sad because
this is what they have done.
And you remember when you were
telling me about the aid earlier?
While they're doing this, the world
Bank getting ready nicely to sign
a $900 million, 900 million
aid package for Honduras.
And then people wonder if they like
then, you know, they say, My God,
you read this book and you say, we
need an enabling business
environment that's going to be up to
these governments to do it.
And if you don't want to do it, and
what can we do? Because we're
America, whatever we do, what do you
want us to do to intervene?
I'm like, no, no, that's not what
I'm asking for.
But when but when it's
happening and you,
the government, have nothing better
to do than to support
this thuggish behavior,
we have a problem.
And when also on top of that, you
using your arms like
the world Bank, the IMF and places
like that to reward almost
bad behavior, we've got a problem.
What do you think is going to
happen? What do you think your $900
million aid package is going to do,
but it hasn't done? Over these past
few years?
What?
What do you think that kicking out
people who have attracted hundreds
of businesses in this area, building
all of these jobs.
What do you think is gonna happen
once you kick them out?
And on top of that, you send a
signal to everybody, but you're not
safe to invest in.
The wealth creators are going to
leave.
Or we're not going to come.
And the poverty is going to stay and
people are going to try to escape
poverty. It means they're going to
come to you to your border.
But maybe that's what you wanted,
Senator Warren. Maybe that's what
you need from us. Maybe the only
thing you need from us is to be a
political pawn.
Because maybe if there was not an
immigration crisis, maybe a
lot of your election, your voters
would simply not even listen to you.
Maybe that's all you care about us.
But if that's the case, we're gonna
have to put it on the table and be
real about this. I'm sick and tired
of this. This need to change.
I'm sick and tired of the lip
service we're being paid because on
one hand, they say, oh, um,
we don't want to intervene.
Yeah, I don't want you to intervene,
but you're intervening and in the
most pervasive way.
So what are we doing?
What are the libertarians doing?
What is everybody doing?
What is anybody who believes in the
rule of law doing?
That's the question for you, Nick.
All right.
What are we doing?
Well, I know that Reason Foundation
is going to be having a, uh,
conference at Prospera, uh,
next year, among other things.
So where, you know, supporting
startup cities and, uh, and
exploring what works and what
doesn't.
Uh, we are going to end
it there.
Uh, McQuaid, thanks so much
for talking to reason.
The new book is The Heart of a
cheetah.
How have we been?
How we have been lied to about
African poverty and what that means
for human flourishing.
We got. Thanks so much for talking.
Thank you so much. It was a
pleasure.